one of the oldest skins in CS go is
skyrocketing in value and the reason
might be graphical I'm sure you all know
that over the past few days
counter-strikes supposedly soon to
arrive Source 2 update has been rumored
reported and everything in between
unsurprisingly this has caused skins
across the board to well stonk a little
bit what is surprising is that while you
expect to see people hoarding Dragon
lures and Gung ears the same can't be
said for lightning strikes I hate
lightning strikes I hate them same core
just uh trade up misery makes me sad and
angry just a few days the initial leak
the oldest covert op in existence the
lightning strike begins
strike was everybody wants one the issue
is that over time it became sort of
outmoded it's basically a PNG slapped
onto the side of a sniper rifle and for
years the community has said that with
better textures it would honestly slap
and with Source 2 on the way it could
look a hell of a lot better very soon